2013 Hong Kong China a satellite spots
an odd yellow floating object in the
harbor totally out of place with its
surroundings so what is this thing it's
big it's yellow it's in the middle of
Hong Kong Harbor one of the busiest
ports in the world it bears no
resemblance to any of the neighboring
boats
looking at the image I've got no idea
what this is this is a pretty unusual
round blob in the middle of Hong Kong
harbour
what on earth could it be if you see a
large yellow object bobbing around in
the ocean there's a good chance it's a
piece of weather recording equipment we
have 1200 weather buoys stationed all
around the world's oceans if I were to
suddenly see something in an unusual
place that's big and yellow my first
inclination would be yes probably a
broken away weather buoy these
specialized buoys gather data on ocean
currents and temperatures to help
forecasters predict weather patterns we
can track them so even if they break
free we can follow where they are and be
able to determine where their precise
location is but there are no records of
missing weather buoys in the area at the
time the image was taken their sheer
size makes them hard to lose weather
buoys are actually quite large but in
the middle of a harbor can't be that has
to be something else
Digital enhancement of the image reveals
the mystery object looks surprisingly
familiar it is a giant rubber duck big
enough to be seen from space
[Music]
Hong Kong's floating duck is a giant art
installation by Dutch artist Florentine
Hofmann
since 2007 the Ducks have been shown all
around the world when one came to Hong
Kong more than eight million people went
to see it this was probably one of the
craziest cases I've ever had to look at
but it was one of the most fun we're
gonna need a bigger bath